Kevin Hart getting ready to sit down
here I just sat down yeah
good to have you it's good to be here
now are you I'm good
I'm extremely well yes okay weird do I
look good you look good I feel I feel
uncomfortable okay what wait is the
chair too deep I don't know what's going
on okay what do you want to do I got
interior set designers here to help
people see this I just don't look
comfortable hey let me do your feet are
touching the floor right maybe that's
what it is maybe my feet yeah don't
worry we'll figure it okay just you guys
can get it in post just I'm doing okay
good see how's life life is great men
I'm excited right now
now the last time we saw each other
mm-hmm I was handing out the Super Bowl
trophy I was trying to get on stage I
was trying to get where you were you
were trying to blow up my spot I was
trying to blow up your spot you know
that was a definitely uh you know what
am i one of my best worst moments that's
what I call it because I would have
invited you up
hmm had I known you were there well I'm
glad you did you know you know you know
all stuff works you know you you drink
enough of it it's going it's gonna get
up on you okay but yeah take us through
watching the game man watch the game all
right so for those people listening if
you don't know I'm a die-hard
Philadelphia fan I'm everything
Philadelphia I'm from Philly I bleed
Philly so the Super Bowl was a big deal
uh I got a suite I took my whole team to
the Super Bowl we watched the game after
1:00 in the Super Bowl I said no we got
to go down on the field they can i it
can't end like this
I got to go and experience this with my
team so I have no passes no laminates
nothing I get down to the field off a
pure Fame and wit everybody I went to as
I'm going down there like sir do you
have passes and I'm like no I'm Kevin
Hart
they just kept letting me by and I guess
it's working and huh say like who you it
like all these people right here all the
black people behind me or with me we get
down to the field we're on the field I
have no idea how we got there we are on
the field confetti is coming down I'm
with the team I'm in like a huddle we're
like doing dances and one of the guys go
oh yo yo the trophy they're bringing out
the trophy and I was like I want I want
to be a part of that and I was like I'm
going to the stage told everybody watch
my wife I'll be back
y'all stay with my wife it was like keV
where you going I said to the stage I'm
going up there so I could be with the
trophy the city the city wants to see me
do it's like I gotta get up there and
I'm just gone like I'm so I'm level as a
band beyond drunk I've just been
drinking all day and I just remember the
security guard putting a hand on my
chest and he's like no not not gonna
happen no he's like I know who you're
not getting on this stage man all right
what now keep in mind all I wanted was a
trophy all this time the trophy was
right behind me all I had to do was turn
around and the trophies right there I
didn't even I didn't even realize that
the trophy was right it was right over
my shoulder the whole time that I was
arguing I could turn I could have got
the bring the trophy up they have this
big long line yeah and it's a gauntlet
where all the players get to touch it
yeah so they bring it right by my mommy
and you're trying to get up to get on
the podium to see the trophy and my mind
is up there yeah the trophy up there I'm
trying to get to the trophy I kept
telling the city the city want to see
this that's what I kept telling them
thank God he didn't let me up there
though I woulda did something stupid I
probably fell off the stage and then I
went from there and they were alive they
were alive doing like a postgame show
and Michael Irvin and I forgot who else
is up there
they invited me okay all right come up
here keV and I got on there and they say
how you feel man and I just I start
cussing I don't know what happened
now the oops y'all live H huh they say
yeah as I man I'm out I'm embarrassing
myself and I just jumped off that stage
and then that's what my wife told me
what I'm doing is ridiculous but you're
you're being a true fan I'm in the
moment
Philadelphia what do you expect me to do
subhan yeah I mean you're not used to
winning no no do you know the people
were eating horse manure and in the city
of Philadelphia you think that my antics
were bad people who were horsemen new
one in Philadelphia yes that's what they
do and people take horse manure hey can
I eat it you just see the clips go
google it Google no no I don't need to
see word for now you should see this
damn this is this'll blow your mind
real real life people were like that you
hear people to sigh like do it do it do
it for the team man this guy just picks
it up has a nice little bite of horse
manure what's your second greatest
Philadelphia sports moment second
greatest Philadelphia sports moment I'll
give you the funniest not great is this
is another funny one I've had a lot of
embarrassing funny ones so playoffs
Sixers last year right we're playing
Boston I'm uh I'm filming a movie and
somehow I get off on I believe it was
like Game three we're in Boston for this
game but it's a big game for the series
I'm like I'm going to Boston
I'm flying to Boston to see the game I
take my friends to Boston I'm in the
front row watching the game I were all
Philadelphia stuff
the fans in Boston love me but I'm
giving them I'm just I'm I'm going at it
I'm going back and forth for the fans
worth 20 it's the most exciting thing
ever I'm laughing ah I told y'all that's
right I'm high-fiving my team come on
give me some oh yeah Ben come here man
Oh
Joell high five right yeah I'm just I'm
just on the sidelines I'm talking trash
Boston comes back Boston takes the lead
fourth quarter doesn't look like we're
gonna win right I'm like come
come on y'all I hear one of the players
of Philadelphia go can't just need to
shut up that's what we use wait are they
blaming you or inspiring the show they
blame me for rolling up the fan they say
you always do this Manny get everybody
all hey I think what you talked about
madam I'm over here being a fan as I
just shut up keV shut up Ben was like
just shut up man I'll say that and then
when I pissed away Wade off
Dwayne Wade gave me like the waywe gave
me like 28 hard and gave me like 50 one
time when I was talking trash too hard
and wait why are you talking trying it's
just what I do it's what I do I make the
game fun the players love it when I come
I'm an entertaining courtside
participate
I'm not sitting courtside just to watch
the game are you like a funny Spike Lee
yes yes I'm Way better than Spike Lee
way better than Spike cuz I'm fun spike
is spike his mean you know spike his
right serious very serious you would
think spike played I don't think spike
could play a lick of basketball could
you take Drake and what basketball yeah
yes Drake doesn't have a athletic bonus
buddy but but he's there front row all
the time yeah Drake's there front row
but is not the same Drake doesn't have
Kevin Hart antics I'm different
could you take Justin Bieber yes do you
not know that I'm a four-time celebrity
game MVP did you guys not tell bayonette
four times then yeah but I've seen the
people in that celebrity all-star game
well I mean look nobody's judging the
character all right okay the best
celebrity you've ever played against you
see the best celebrity basketball wise I
would say you know could play basketball
Brian McKnight can play basket you know
but he's about six four yeah we can play
but I mean I can play I get slim after
that have you played against George
Clooney or Adam Sandler uh those guys
stinkin Adam Sandler would own you
I had him stand over not on no he would
own you Adam Sandler would not mean I've
seen Adam play Adam would own you do Nam
I'm starting by varsity basketball I'm
really an athlete like I'm I'm the real
deal in basketball did I would pay to
see you Sandler one on one that would be
a stupid pavement that's your maken it's
not a it's not a good purchase for you
it's not how good were you as a point
guard that's really good who plays the
game in the NBA like you played point
guard in high school I'm probably saying
Chris Paul yeah Oh Chris Paul like right
now cause he's not playing Chris Paul
and his prom I mean you're looking at me
let me tell you so I'm not played in the
church league averaged about 17 points
in a church League it was all pastors I
was dominating this leagues
you own the pastor's with any nuns in
their plan no no there's pastors and
deacons I'm the real deal man when it
comes to sports I can look basketball
swimming I would say badminton but you
were great in swimming in badminton yes
swimming I was actually really really
good I spent you know the movie PDR it
was it was based off of my bro swim team
for the other department recreation I
was Junior Olympics I was real dealing
I'm serious like swimming 50-meter
freestyle swam like a twenty nineteen
hundred meter freestyle used to scold
like 51 52
I was just small so so next you're gonna
tell me you could take Michael Phelps in
swimming yeah if he gave me if Michael
Phelps gave me a lap and you were going
to laps I can beat him I need a whole
lap oh you know what there's there's a
whole new show here he's got a spot man
it's you versus Michael Phelps in
swimming I'm dominating Adam Sandler in
Bouska that's the easiest one of my life
Oh Drake easy as one of my life
bad mitt and I gotta find somebody
somebody play left-handed too you're
right-handed badminton and trouble bad
man you in trouble I may be in one of
them I may be in a top three best bad
man players in the world if ya have you
have you probably find my ranking I did
a tournament I was
tournament in Budapest I was in Budapest
and I did a Badman tournament and I've
ranked wait are you being honest
you got a Google it look you're all over
there with the laptops while I lie
google Kevin Hart badminton the whole
bunch of stats go fly it you played
badass Schmidt in this one will tell you
why in badminton bowling I'm a great
bowler there's nothing that I cannot do
man there's nothing that I can't do Dan
I chose comedy okay I could have easily
been dick Comedy choose you or did you
choose it I chose it I mean it was tons
of stuff it's because somebody had to
say you should do this for a living
right I mean they said that with
everything I mean modeling there was a
chance where you have a bit of mom I
could have been a model there was a
chance where I remember people there was
a long discussion and they're like Kevin
look you know it's up to you I mean at
the end of the day the camera loves you
do you wanna do you wanna model and I
was like I mean look I don't know and it
was like well people want to see you and
this is at the time I was fitness
modeling then I thought I'm going to
hand modeling and then I did like tons
of modeling like it was like contour in
like just different stylistic sugar ham
oh yeah I used to
Heinz commercials you know Heinz ketchup
yeah look at the commercial google it
you'll see my hand you'll see my hand
yes oh yeah you'll see my hand okay yeah
I'm not lying - there's only one
commercial of Heinz ketchup with a black
hand it's my hand go look at it right
now
my wife was a hand model well she were
young professional he'll probably know
her name is Susan Susan yeah hold on let
me formal introductions - he's got a new
movie called the upside and you're in it
with Nicole Kidman yes Bryan Cranston
yes - amazing actors and actresses and
it opens in theaters Friday I'm excited
now this is a remake of a French French
movie
so okay yes what attracted you to do
this money it's a serious movie it's a
serious movie it's a it's a serious
movie would it would a a personal
undertone it's it's as it's funny
moments but they're grounded funny
moments so you're not normal Kevin that
you've seen okay this is a more serious
version of myself much more grounded
much more realistic authentic and true
to the true story of course so the
French version was a very successful
film it did amazing and we felt that you
know doing a remake and kind of
adjusting it to fit today's times
modernizing a little bit what uh what
would be good when the idea came up I
was all for it once I found out that
Bryan Cranston Nicole Kidman were gonna
be a part of it I was even more blown
away and it was an opportunity to take
my fan base in a different direction you
know I definitely had the talent and
ability to do more serious roles it's
just about finding the right material
and this is the first one that I found
so the first of hopefully many Bryan
Cranston's one of the great actors of
our generation he is I would say
probably the best I mean you know I
noted that that that list when you start
to say the best is a small list on the
short list but he's a hundred percent on
that list I mean I learned so much from
just watching him saying hi he
approaches his day to day but when you
know that he played how in malcolm in
the middle' yes many played Walter White
in Breaking Bad that's range it's it's
unbelievable range I mean when you when
you look at his resume you know the guy
can he can do whatever he wants he gave
me a prop from the movie really the the
thing that he would make his you know
what he'll has stuff in yeah because
he's a quadriplegic yeah and so he oh
wow yeah yeah you're talking about the
the the from the scene yes the the fake
the fake thing to raise it to raise his
mouth he gave that he gave that's yes he
gave it to me Wow why would you why
would you take it why would you take
that because it's from the movie
well yeah but I mean that's not it's a
pretty cool thing to have
I mean if you say so I would have took
it out of my you collect memorabilia
from movies no nothing no I was you
don't get cars that you drive in or
anything like that no I have memories I
was there
oh you don't want a piece of something
no I just go watch it I don't need a
piece of it I don't want to collect this
like Kevin Costner in Bull Durham has
this beautiful Mustang yeah at the end
of the movie drives off it yeah you got
to keep it he kept it
yeah well that stuff adds up yeah I
think if you just keep you just keep
keeping a bunch of stuff in these movies
you're gonna look up you have a bunch of
stuff but that's a bunch of valuable
stuff I mean um I don't want to because
my wife I mean I got a Smithsonian of
sports memorabilia do you really yeah
how like if you had to put a number on
how many items you probably have how
many items yeah how many do you think I
got guys Paulie I honestly probably 200
good things really up in a studio in
Connecticut good things yeah define
interesting give me give me like okay
when Fergie did the black eyed peas did
halftime at the Super Bowl and they had
to create a dress for her
they created a bust for her a metal bust
okay so she gave me the bust and then
autographed that Wow said breast wishes
Fergie that's one of a kind
that's one of a kind I'm one of one now
here's a question can you get that
evaluated to see what it would be worth
can you get all that stuff evaluated the
jack it's priceless to me it's priceless
if Ryan Leaf had been drafted by the
Colts instead of Peyton Manning uh-huh
they made a Jersey for Ryan Leaf on
draft day and he kept the Colts Jersey
okay and I have that he autographed that
so we have that anime that's one of one
but if nobody knows about it what do
they think you're lying that this is one
of one well he signed it whatever what
if I don't believe you why wouldn't you
believe me I believe that you were a
great badminton player Paulie you
googled to see if he was a great
badminton player and what did you find
out was Kevin Hart a great badminton
player great he way at once he was
ranked in the world yes
mr. Q I don't know why you wouldn't
believe that yeah I got it I found it Oh
all this stuff is searchable information
it's all searchable okay I googled Kevin
Hart hand model see Kevin Hart comedy
comes up second badminton stories come
up first thank you rightfully so thank
you but what about the four-time MVP in
the celebrity all-star game oh I don't
know why you don't believe me I swear I
wish you could go with me to China I
can't even walk the streets because of
my badminton career like literally when
I touched down in China like it's I'm
signing bad man records left and right
all day all day it's so tough for me
sometimes because I'm like guys I'm no
longer this guy I'm an actor now and I
know okay you know um Fritzie who works
in the back row he's the one that
reached out to your people to book you
he's an aspiring aspiring comedian
really he's been on stage three times he
was at Caroline's okay Comedy Store okay
and once in Minnesota okay so that's it
so once every eight months he'll make it
appear so once every eight months for
two yeah I think I've been told you got
to do it a hundreds of times to even be
remotely good well it seems like you're
persistent about it I could tell you
serious are you why
wise so far feeling in-between I don't I
just got to get at it more and I got the
work responsibilities here and family
and you know it's not the kind of thing
where I can just kind of drop everything
and you're sitting right and tour the
country but I do enjoy making people
laugh and I have the utmost respect for
what you guys do and you know the
anxiety that I experienced going up
there and knowing you may bomb and you
say something which has happened often
in that laughing you know but the high
of getting people hysterical laughing is
pretty awesome well man I think that you
should do it not not many can I think
once you find out that you have the
ability to make people laugh you'll fall
in love with the craft even more it's
honestly one of the best jobs in the
world man it's therapeutic it's therapy
it's hard though it's not you know what
it is it's it's hard to get past the the
mental thought of it being hard when you
realize that you can be yourself if
you're naturally funny you're a funny
guy you're naturally funny when you get
up there and realize that your natural
ability to be funny can carry you
through an entire set
are you fine what's the worst moment
though when you're not funny
mm-hmm you've had a bad night before I
don't have bad nights you've never had a
bad night doing stand-up
you didn't say ever oh come on I'm gonna
talk about ever you're somebody and just
in general yeah I've had I've had bad
nights in the beginning but I look at
him as good nights cuz you learn from
those bad nights well how bad was bad I
got hit in the face with a buffalo wings
I might do a buffalo wing a true story
true story no I believe everything you
tell me from now on I was performing at
a UH I was in Atlantic City performing
at a place called Sweet Cheeks which was
there was a male revue so so basically
they booked the comedy show like like to
be in between the acts so the dancers
yeah the dancers so you know so it's a
male strip club male strip club you know
at the time you know money's not coming
so I gotta do what I gotta tell her you
go to Suite change so I'll go to Suite
sheets which was a good gig and I'm
telling my joke and I just heard
somebody in the back they like they were
saying what what that ain't it man you
talkin about
let me do my stuff man it says buffalo
wings a little bit of sauce one of my
I'll start blinking big black guy stood
up that's my time I see y'all later
strip down to your g-string at work that
probably the gap he got me out of the
moment the movie is the upside and it's
Kevin Hart
along with Julianne margulies yes Tate
Donovan Nicole Kidman and Bryan Cranston
who joins us on the show tomorrow opens
in theaters this Friday if the Eagles
win it again anything if I saying if if
the Eagles that your being I think
that's I don't think that's fair
okay would you take Nick Foles now as
your starting quarterback 104 ever you
have to next year you have to / of
course and what you have to okay just
throwing it out there you have to I'm
wondering if he could play let's say
they go to the Super Bowl again yes
let's say they win the Super Bowl like
how how does Nick Foles lose that job
Nick Foles can't lose that ok I'm just
throwing it out there
well it's nothing throw out I think
right now you you're looking at what I
would like to call a closer you're
looking at a guy that's proving himself
to be a clutch and crunch time perform I
know and Carson Wentz is an amazing
court of might just ask questions
I'm an answer to all I do I know sports
and I well you know well well ball
bowling yeah I just I just know and
right now what I do know is that Nick
Foles is the heart and soul of the
football team because his story is what
motivates these guys to actual move I'm
gonna get you a press credential next
time the Eagles win the Superman you
know what I tell you what I'm gonna take
you over there because I don't want to
get a hand on my chest I really feel
good about Sunday no I feel like we have
a very good chance as shocking New
Orleans because I think New Orleans
thinks it's a easier game then it's
going to be because of the the first
game where we got blown out so I'm
expecting big things thanks for stopping
by
Thank You Man I like you dad I gotta get
you some memorabilia hey I might have my
people bring a badminton racket here I'm
a silent I want you to put it I want you
to put it with yourself as a one-on-one
I don't know it's a platinum badminton
yeah you'll never see a racket like this
racket is worth means enough all right
don't worry about it just I don't want
to tell you just you're gonna be blown
away when you see it okay but don't be
saying this and they're not produced I'm
gonna send you a bad man right it's not
about saying don't say it if you're not
gonna do it do that Dan I wouldn't do
that to you you're a good guy man the
movie is the upside in theaters on
Friday Thank You keV we're back after
this in the Dan Patrick show
[Music]
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]